my art is very much so focused on my own
struggles with mental illness both as a
coping mechanism but also as a way to
kind of articulate very precisely how I
feel in a way that's not like verbal my
name is Ponte a beret she I have sickle
cell zero beta thalassemia
it's a genetic blood condition my mom
had an unexpressed gene for sickle cell
my dad had an unexpressed gene for
thalassemia and I got the least likely
but worst combination of genes where I
have both of them expressed so I have
both the diseases the pain aspect of it
comes from the blood cells getting
caught between my bones or sickling and
creating this pain response that can
manifest in bones joints nerves when I
turned 14 the pain all of a sudden
became much more severe and constant so
it was a big change to all of a sudden
like not have the pain ever subside and
kind of learn how to live with that I
was like isolated in the hospital all
the time at home all the time when my
pain started getting really bad and my
depression and anxiety started getting
really bad I kind of lost all the things
that I like to do or the things that I
would turn to for coping whether it was
like reading books or even listening to
music or watching TV it just kind of
like would be just noise that I couldn't
really focus on or enjoy I never just
like picked up a pen and a piece of
paper I've been like I'm gonna just draw
so when I started doing that it was like
the most amazing feeling I need
something you know obviously like
everyone does like when you're in pain
to distract you but my art I really
quickly realized was what I needed to
cope with my mental illness that was
very very intense my sickle-cell like
people actually understand and are
actively trying to help me and with my
mental illness people are like well if I
don't see the symptoms and I don't care
and you're better
honestly all comes back down to the fact
that it's so stigmatized and
misunderstood creating my art for myself
and not for anyone else is like
consumption really like I'm not putting
it out there expecting people to like it
or to want to see more and all the girls
that I draw like they love roses roses
is like this kind of like weapon almost
like these things that are like spying
if you can like cut someone with it or
you know impale someone with it when I
draw my girls when I draw the for the
people that I draw and they are in pain
the literal sense like the physical
sense of pain where there's like a knife
in their neck or like a rose poking
through their hand or like they're
squeezing a rose so hard that blood
dripping down their hands or like they
have a bloody nose or like they're
bleeding from their mouth like things
that you associate with whoa something's
wrong like that must really hurt all of
these things that are painful dangerous
like you look at them and you're like
out that looks like it really hurts
those are me expressing what my mental
illness feels like in ways that people
can like take in and understand a degree
of pain creating something tangible out
of something that is like hyper and
tangible to share a pain or to like
share a sensation like that like a heart
sensation it makes people feel
uncomfortable that makes people feel
vulnerable and that's what I think we
need people to feel in order for them to
understand honestly women told us is
like and to like make a change and move
[Music]